scp-035 versus scp-106  the possessive mask versus the old man  which one of these two incredibly evil  scps would win out in a battle let's  find out 035 is a theatrical mask that  takes over and kills its victims with  its powerful brainwaves it also leaks a  corrosive black fluid that breaks down  human bodies this is something that it  actually has in common with scp-106  which also leaks corrosive black fluid  in addition to being able to walk  through walls and drag people into its  nightmare pocket dimension we'd argue  that the truly frightening outcome here  is not a fight but an alliance if 106  was able to wear 035 and survive the  result could be an anomaly with their  combined power set all the terrifying  abilities of 106 with added intelligence  and mental manipulation abilities from  zero three five a true force to be  reckoned with